Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And Ah,
I'm checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on you.
I really need to check in on you.
At least half of you.
A little less than half old g shoes.
Make sure you guys are right.
There's a lot of crying going on out there.
Okay?
Jesus fucking Christ.
I've never seen so many fucking adults crying in my life.
What is with all the fucking crying?
I get it.
Your person didn't win,
but Jesus Christ,
you're making the left look horrible.
Going to Canada.
I love this shit where people like threatening like share,
share goes.
If Trump wins,
I'm going to go to Canada.
It's like,
who gives a fuck?
You know?
I didn't even know you was still here.
Here.
Look,
I'm not saying I'm happy.
I wasn't happy with either one of these people.
All right.
Yeah.
Um,
but the level of fucking arrogance of celebrities during all of this shit was
just,
it's such a,
a whole other level.
Do you realize how fucking arrogant you are that you're making this to you?
Basically,
you're threatening that if your candidate doesn't get in,
your going to leave the country and your ego is so fucking big.
You think somebody going like,
well,
I want to vote for Trump,
but if he gets elected,
we lose share.
I got you.
Beat the Fuck Outta here.
Heard Barbra Streisand.
Really?
You're going to leave fucking Malibu to go live in Manitoba?
Railey you fucking
go ahead and do it.
I'll give you 40 bucks for your house that only get yet that 9,000 fucking acres
up there.
Go ahead.
Go,
go,
move up to yellow knife.
The dumbest shit.
But I literally think like that's the level of ego that you have to have as like
an actor or a comedian or something like that.
Literally too.
I mean,
I know,
I guess I talk about it,
but you know,
I fuck around.
I trashed replied.
Now I told you guys who to vote for or whatever.
I just trashed.
And both I tried to evenly,
but that fucking level that people take it to where they just start,
uh,
you know,
I kind of was on,
I was on Conan last night,
which was really difficult show,
uh,
to do last night because,
you know,
people I like fucking stunned out here.
They can,
they can't believe it,
um,
as,
I can't believe it in San Francisco,
Berkeley,
fucking New York City and all that type of shit.
Um,
so it was kind of weird.
It was like going on like right after a funeral.
I felt so.
Um,
but,
uh,
I really think this is just my own opinion.
What do you guys,
what do you guys think about celebrities endorsing a,
uh,
a candidate?
Because I think the candidates,
they also kind of reach out to people a little bit.
Like I like,
I,
I've never understood that.
Like,
why would I be like,
you know,
who are some of the people,
some of the fucking people that have done it,
like I just,
I just don't understand.
It's,
Oh,
you know I was going to vote this way,
but the guy from my three kings told me to do,
Oh,
the other movie where he tries to get the sky miles.
The Guy who did the movie about this guy getting the sky miles is telling me
this should be the person to lead the free world.
You know,
I got a lot of feelings on our gun control,
but let me check in with Sean Penn first.
See what he has to say.
The level of fucking arrogance
that you have to have.
I don't know.
It's a fine line cause it's like,
all right,
well it's good that they're involved politically,
but like you know,
there's a lot that once you're famous then they're actually going to put a
camera on you and then you're going to start talking.
You know,
it's the same thing.
It's when you become a huge fan of your t,
you're a big fan of your team,
right.
And you know,
you're always sitting down,
but the nose bleeds and then all of a sudden you get a part on a Sitcom and then
they got you sitting down there and then your team's doing well.
And next thing you know,
the stick and the microphone in the face of an actor,
right.
To be or not to be a,
what do you think buffalo has to do here in the second half?
Well,
I thought I'd like to see you out of your checking down a little bit.
It's like,
I don't know.
I don't understand.
I'm pain.
I'm it.
You know what?
In defense of celebrities,
regular people do the same thing on the news and they get away with it.
Cause you don't know what their names are.
You see it all the time on these,
uh,
you know,
when you watch the news,
if he ever watched the news,
they always go,
yeah,
we went out on the street to ask people what they thought about this new target
that's going up.
I think it's going to take away jobs.
Eh,
you know,
I just think that downtown area,
we don't need that.
There's always that fun
person,
right?
So maybe that's what it is.
That's that person is no different than any of those other people.
It's just,
I don't know.
I think once you get to a certain level,
you,
you kinda need to gracefully shut the fuck up.
All right.
Having said that,
Kim's,
anybody explain to me why they're making such a big deal about the transition of
power here is far as,
you know,
we hope that it's going to be graceful and we hope that it's going to be the,
when Obama came in,
George Bush was very graceful,
gracious.
He was very blood.
They all,
they all were by entire life.
I've never,
you know,
Reagan did knock on the White House door and Jimmy was just like,
Hey,
get the fuck out.
And we don't want any,
there's literally camera's on.
That's another thing too.
There's cameras filming you as this transition happens.
Everybody,
everybody's always,
you know,
you're going to be grace gracious.
They know where you live.
You know,
they don't like each other.
this one's gonna be particularly fucking weird,
you know,
considering the sizable overtly racist individuals that,
I don't know what the fuck they were here,
but they gravitated towards Trump.
So considering,
you know,
Barack being the first black president to now let this guy into,
I dunno,
according to people I hear,
I don't,
I mean fucking looked it up was endorsed by the clan.
This was just fucking nuts.
Well that's it.
That was the end.
It's the end and now it's over and now everybody can fucking move on.
And um,
you know,
I got,
I did call last night,
I think a,
I think it went as well as it could have gone.
And then of course,
you know,
I get people giving me shit.
You know,
I was trying to say,
look,
whoever's president,
it's not really going to affect my fucking day to day.
And then of course [inaudible] you fucking white guy.
But with Ebay they,
it,
it's like,
yeah,
I get it,
I get it.
But your day to day,
your day to day,
this is my,
and this is supposed to be uplifting by the way.
All right.
Knowing full well that the world isn't fair.
Okay.
And that some people start way closer to the finish line than others.
That's just how it is.
All right.
And there's advantages and disadvantages to that.
You know,
if you got to run further,
you always think that other guy.
Yeah,
he's fucking Angel's wings.
All,
all he's gotta do is just fucking go fright from there to there.
Right?
And you see all these fucking rich kids that got drug fucking problems because
they have no worries in life.
They're fucking red alerts and all that type of shit.
Everybody wants to think if you filthy stinking fucking rich that you just skip
around you,
life is fucking awesome.
Um,
I've done enough corporate gigs to see that there's not a lot of happiness over
there.
They're fucking with really rich people.
I gotta tell you out in Malibu,
you know,
Neil always wants to go out to Malibu.
She loves the fucking beach.
And we go out there and his fucking,
you know,
the seaside restaurants and shit.
You know,
what's your cool,
it's great.
You fucking watch people surfing.
It's awesome.
You go out,
you have a couple of crab legs and then you get the fuck out of there.
But there's a mall over there.
All right,
the Malibu Mall,
whatever the fuck.
He go over there and I'm just telling you,
the people over there,
I cannot put my finger on it.
They are fucking weird,
really rich people.
There's,
there's some sort of fucking disconnect.
I don't know what's going on with them.
They just there,
I sent it to me.
I go,
what,
what is,
what the fuck is what these people,
there's no vibe.
There's no laughing,
what's going on?
And she just,
she goes,
the board.
That's what it is.
I Dunno.
I did gigs.
Um,
um,
yeah,
way back in the day I did some gigs out on the Hamptons,
another place with like super rich people and they just fucking weird.
They'd sit there and they all look at each other.
They're looking you up and down.
Like I showed up and immediately they were just like,
all right,
this guy's in here for the day is a day tripper.
Should look at his fucking sneakers.
Yeah,
we'll get his fucking orange Afro.
Nobody has red hair and makes it in this world before they met Donald Trump on
the fuck.
Did he go from a Brunette to fucking looking like me in seventh grade?
I don't understand it.
Um,
anyways,
but yeah,
you make your own fucking opportunity and I think,
uh,
okay.
You know,
is is depressing.
Is that,
is it,
I always looked at that like a,
I dunno,
I always try to see like,
what the fuck I can do.
Um,
I just can't believe that all the names that I'm hearing now,
if Jesus Christ,
Newt Gingrich,
Rudy Giuliani,
these fucking guys are coming back.
Jesus Christ,
that's like that Stallone movie where he took all the fucking action heroes from
back in the day,
Seagal and they all got to be level one last fucking thing.
Unless it's ahead,
then we'll make like three of them.
What was that called?
The fucking
last gladiator erection hero to fucking,
I dunno.
Drink your juice in the hood.
I what the fuck with the expendables?
Yeah.
This is like,
he's bringing back,
this is like the Republican expendables.
He's bringing all these guys back trying to think of another classic name he's
got to go for from way back in the day.
Somebody didn't die,
I dunno,
whatever.
But she knows something.
It's over.
Get on with your fucking lives.
And uh,
you know,
yeah.
There's all these protests at colleges.
I don't know what they're protesting.
I don't quite get it.
It's like there was an election.
It was legal and your person lost.
Um,
I guess they're just voicing their displeasure with the fact that this guy's in
there.
I,
dude,
I cannot fucking believe that the host of the apprentice is now president of the
United States,
and that people are this excited and hopeful.
Half the country is excited and hopeful.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
You know,
the,
the most amazing thing ever,
our broke ass people that are Republicans,
that's the most amazing fucking thing on the planet.
So you guys in guys,
he's gonna make it great again for you.
All right?
Please keep checking in on me throughout the years.
I want to know how your life individually will become great again.
Oh,
this country will become great again.
So then your life will be great again.
All those fucking people who are galloping sideways.
Um,
okay.
I love how he wants to fuck it.
He doesn't want to have healthcare,
but he wants to build a fucking wall from California,
New Mexico.
Oh,
how much money is that?
Gonna fucking cost Uber.
The job that's going to create you the fuck out of here.
That's a,
that's a government job.
Do you know,
bet all of these.
Fuck me.
You know something?
That's
one thing that they'll never police,
but that fucking bullshit.
Where these contractors,
they get these government jobs to build shit and they charge 10 times the amount
that they should,
and these politicians just throw the fucking money around and they don't give a
fuck,
or they have to do it.
Whatever the deal is.
You know,
like the math on this whole thing.
Do you realize like $7 billion was spent to get somebody a job that pays 500
grand a fucking year?
You know why?
Cause I bet it was,
I bet it was a bunch of people that build forms,
you know,
foundations and shit.
That's what,
you know,
they were like,
oh man,
I gotta get that.
I it,
I got to build the wall,
man.
You know,
some go with the fucking rusted out pickup truck
do to fight,
get that fucking job.
All our problems are going to be over.
I'll be building that for the rest of my life.
Um,
what a fucking crazy God damn time.
You know,
everybody wondering how the fuck this happen.
I think you know what it is,
is people are still digging out of what happened in 2008 and it would've been
nice if one of these fucking pussy politicians would have said something about
the fucking bankers,
you know?
Um,
I dunno,
we will see what happens,
but uh,
yeah,
boy.
Oh boy.
I'll tell you.
You know,
it was great though,
was when I went to go to the elect to vote,
I fucking had,
I look through all the fucking,
uh,
propositions,
everything.
I had all my,
filled it all out,
like a fucking old lady.
And I went in there and I was just like,
Bang,
boom,
boom.
I,
I blew through the whole thing,
knew exactly what I wanted to vote for.
Actually felt a mildly informed this time.
Um,
so
he just showed up in his own fucking,
this guy's a gangster.
I'm literally,
we shall see.
You know what's funny is my wife had on a MSNBC,
by the way,
you know what I was doing during the election where I just kept flipping back
and forth to like,
uh,
who,
if whoever was losing,
I would start watching them.
I would put on like CNN,
you know,
I put that on Fox at first in the beginning.
And once they started looking like they were winning and they were surprised and
I went over to a,
the CNN thing and then I went down to the comedy store and uh,
did Doug Stan hopes live podcast.
And,
uh,
I,
that was the most amazing election I've ever fucking seen.
That it was like,
it was riveting for hours.
It never got boring.
Um,
and as much as I don't like Trump,
I didn't like Hillary either.
Uh,
I have to say,
watching people crying,
um,
uh,
white people,
I want to say white people.
If I see somebody of crying on my gut,
Jesus,
this is brutal,
but just somebody white crying,
like I'm still white America.
Um,
there was just something funny about that to me,
like people hugging and stuff.
Um,
blew my mind,
blew my mind.
How many people just still look at Hillary Clinton.
Like she's not a complete dishonest piece of shit and like the best I could get
anybody to say.
It's like,
yeah,
but they're all like that.
Um,
all right.
Are you guys done amp done enough of this shit?
All right,
let's watch the gracious,
the Obamas,
they,
where they shook hands,
they were very gracious.
And this is what makes the United States,
the United States,
this,
this peaceful passing of power.
Or this is what makes the Americas,
the United States of America,
those of,
well,
I don't know why this is like such a,
an amazing fucking thing.
This is just like just a different head that's owned by the same what fucking 20
corporations out pill with your hacky conspiracy theory,
but isn't it?
Isn't that what it is?
Well,
isn't it?
Um,
anyways,
let's move on everybody.
Let's move on to a little bit of bread and circus there.
Um,
so this,
guess what just went on sale?
Everybody,
um,
as of yesterday,
promoted it on,
on the Conan show,
uh,
Conan O'brien's show,
um,
the fifth annual Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit as always at the New York City
Center.
Uh,
tickets are already on sale once we pay for the house.
All the money goes to his,
uh,
his mother and his family.
And,
um,
it's been such a great event that we do every year and um,
and has had an amazing effect on,
uh,
on people's lives that he loved.
It's been a great thing.
And,
um,
as I've said year after year,
the reason why we do whatever years,
cause I always hate when somebody,
somebody passes and it's just like you do like that one fucking benefit.
Like okay,
here's a sack.
Aleut I hope this will last you for the next 60 fucking years.
Um,
we all know Patrice so much that we all decided that we were going to do it
every year and um,
make sure that uh,
we continued to take care of the people that he was taken care of and the people
that he loved.
So,
um,
it is,
it is a great cause.
It is 100% honest.
It's something you can get behind.
None of the comedians are going to be dressed in pink,
none of that shit.
You know,
it'll be a,
it'll be a great thing.
And um,
I'm also doing a,
the comp come home benefit with Denis Leary,
Cam Neely,
uh,
this weekend and um,
oh Jesus.
Oh Jesus did fucking Billy red faced by some cigars.
Holy fucking shit.
I've never smoked these before,
but um,
I'm not going to tell you where I got them.
Let's see.
Let me take a picture of him here.
I actually left him down in the fucking humor door there,
dude.
Why is this fucking phone so difficult with me?
Um,
a reality TV show start people with an orange toupee is now going to be the
leader of the free world.
That's what you did then half of the country feels good about us.
I can't fucking believe it.
Oh Jesus.
You know what it is?
It's just none of it is really that funny.
It's just not funny.
The whole thing was just fun.
How to fuck a on the right and the left people,
how to fuck did we end up with those two?
How did that happen?
I just kept thinking back,
but like all the fucking candidates just stunk.
God,
they stunk.
That QT pioneer camel hair coat.
The fuck is she doing now?
What are you talking about?
I'm sorry,
I got on Msnbc here.
Where the hell's that goddamn camera here.
All right,
there it is.
There it is.
Okay.
It's Ah,
fuck.
It's a blurry goddamn picture on more old
Hoyle Dell.
Oh fuck.
I can't read it.
I took a blurry picture of it,
then I thought if I,
if I zoomed in,
it would somehow get better.
Um,
wait,
wait.
Sorry.
Sorry again.
The fuck is it?
Oh,
there it is.
Okay.
Julio,
Yo de Monterrey,
not
Monterri Siri,
La Hoya and apologies to anybody Latino.
Listen to this 56 ring gauge.
It's like a fucking two hours smoke.
I got a fucking box of those goddamn things and bringing it to comics,
come home and I'm hoping,
uh,
there's gonna be some cigar smokers there.
Um,
oh,
it's going to be such a great event.
Going to be a great event.
So anyways,
I have not been paying attention to shit,
but editing my new fucking special and a,
I'm probably gonna add another fucking standup date while I'm out here is I'm
waiting for my kitchen to get done,
which still is not done.
It was supposed to be done by now,
but then,
you know,
we ran into the cloth wiring,
so,
uh,
you know,
and then the place we were staying at the haunted fucking house,
the person who owned it came back.
So now we're,
we're in a hotel and,
uh,
has a little kitchen,
right?
So I keep saying the Nia,
you know,
it's fucking hilarious.
It has this little kitchen and has pots and pans,
but it has no spatula,
had nothing that you could fucking cook with.
It's hilarious.
They just had like the,
the pants and,
um,
so I was like,
oh,
I see that fucking game plan.
They gonna act like there's a kitchen and then I got to give me any fucking
shit.
You know,
they're gonna have a couple of props.
Is looks like a Goddamn like sitcoms kitchen.
They've got a couple of glasses up front and then there's like nothing else.
Even like the cereal bowls I like so fucking shallow.
It's like a,
it's like a deep plate,
you know,
you pour a little bit of milk in.
It's already going over the sides.
So I drove back to my house and got all my fucking tongs and spatulas and all
that type of ship and I'm,
now I'm viewing it like,
um,
I'm going to try to beat them at their own game.
Right.
Cause you don't stay in hotels fucking expensive,
right.
So Nia keeps filling an order.
God Damn Room Service.
And I keep saying to,
I was like,
Nia,
every time we eat in the kitchen,
all right,
the terrorist's loose.
Okay.
This,
this is a victory for us.
I fucking,
I haven't,
I have not enjoyed food the way I have.
When you are in a fucking hotel and you actually buy food,
you know,
and start cooking up a mate eggs the other day,
right?
Simple Shit.
Just filling myself up.
I still got that fucking elk that Rogan gave me.
You know,
I made a little American shops,
so we with that shit.
And um,
I don't know.
My wife,
she's telling me,
right,
let's go downstairs.
I'll meet you downstairs.
You know,
they just love,
like women are hilarious.
They just loved that whole,
the whole scene,
right?
Oh you got like a fountain down there and you said in a sunny area,
they have like a little tent is nice.
Why don't you want to come to town?
They just wear you down.
You just like quiz.
It's like fucking nine zillion dollars for fucking eggs.
I know,
but it's nice.
Like fuck.
All right,
fine.
here we go.
The NHL,
this was out trying to get to,
we got the Columbus blue jackets.
You'll be,
uh,
the Boston Bruins.
Maybe I can finally watch your fucking game.
You know,
maybe like the fucking NHL network here.
Something.
I don't fucking know.
I don't even know what the fuck's on our team.
All I know is our first line as far as I remember was
Marshawn Bergie and a pasta not going.
I don't know what the fuck else is on the thing.
Bruins forwards d more.
No idea.
Patrice Bergeron
back as we had last year.
David Craigy,
Brad Marshawn Volesky is back.
Nash.
I don't know who the fuck that is.
Jimmy,
Jimmy Hayes.
Ryan's Boba tea Shaller no idea.
Pastor knuck.
CISGENIC Zeigarnik.
No idea.
Okay.
And I don't know anybody else.
Somebody get
Myla Ciara McQuade and I'm okay.
Both millers to crew.
Crew back.
Both millers it back.
Cruise back.
Mcquade Shara.
Okay.
I don't know.
Do we never fucking recovered,
man?
Whatever that fucking move was to free up all the salary cap money when we just
basically imploded the team.
We're two years into this shit.
I don't know.
It just seems like it's,
this is,
it's the same as like last year as far like the level
that we're at,
where we're going to,
I don't know.
Joe Barton at said it best.
He goes,
you did the worst fucking thing you could do is you,
you,
you missed the playoffs on the last day,
so you lost all the playoff revenue and then you're going in.
You're not going to be,
you didn't suck.
So you could be like fucking,
you know,
Toronto and have a shot at someone like a
Austin Matthews,
you know,
whatever the fuck are you going to do.
As long as the Canadians don't win it,
I'm happy.
I'm a happy,
happy fucking guy.
All right,
let's read a little bit of advertising here and then I'm going to give you my
predictions for a Trump presidency.
What's going to change how he's going to make it great?
He's gonna make it great again.
All right.
A legacy box,
everybody.
This is,
this is the greatest fuck in the world.
The legacy box.
No legacies like pass down,
right?
He's a legacy.
All right.
What was the last time you watched home movies,
your home movies.
If you're like most Americans as a box in your closet of videotapes,
film videos and photos that don't get watched and taken out worse,
they are actually deteriorating.
Introducing legacy box as simple and affordable way to get your recorded moments
digitally preserved on a DVD or thumb drive.
Here's how it works.
Load legacy box with your old tapes,
films,
pictures and auto audio recordings and send it back.
You'll get them back in a couple of weeks on DVD or a convenient thumbdrive
ready to watch,
share and relive.
That's pretty cool.
Just make sure if he did a personal porno,
you don't accidentally send that legacy box.
Takes care of everything and provides updates at every step of the process.
That's why over 250,000 families have used them.
The Huffington Post,
Booboo,
parents magazine,
USA Today and the view are all talking about legacy box.
Even Disney has trusted legacy box to digitize their media.
And for a limited time,
go to legacy
box.com/bird to get 40% discount on your water.
That's legacy
box.com/burr one more time.
Legacy box.com/bar
uh,
with everyone gathered for the holidays.
Now is the perfect time to share all those old photos and cassettes and home
videos.
Go to legs.
We got it.
Lazy
box.com/bernie at 40% off you fucking discount on your legacy box that I
mentioned.
It's legacy box.
All right,
Joe Rogan's company.
Everybody Audit,
uh,
on it has a new product is called emulsified MCT oil.
Mct Oil is one of the fastest sources of clean fuel for the body and the brain.
It's one of the best ways to power up your performance at kickstart.
A weight management program.
Uh,
there's lots of MCT oil brands out there are there?
I've never heard of it,
but there's none emulsify none.
Like a mulcify MCT oil from Onnit available in three delicious flavors.
Uh,
the Billy red phase flavors,
coconut,
vanilla and strawberry,
coconut head,
vanilla skin,
strawberry,
pubes,
emulsified MCT oil mixes like a cream easily in your morning coffee without the
need for a blender.
No mess,
no cleanup.
You can even mix it into your favorite foods right now.
If you go to [inaudible] dot com slash bar,
you can get on it.
So mulcify and MC tea oil for 12% off.
That's on it.
O n n I t.com/bill to get emulsified MCT oil for 12% off.
And for any reason,
if you don't like it,
they'll give you your money back.
No questions asked at acts to ask.
You've got nothing to lose.
Go to [inaudible] dot com now and get on it.
Alright.
Oh,
Jay's is one of our favorite.
Look who's back.
Get sold.
Zip.
Are you hiring well?
Are you?
Do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates?
Posting your job in one place.
While that isn't enough to find quality candidates,
if you want to find the perfect hire,
you need to post your job on all the job sites.
And now you can with zip
brewed up.com.
You can post your job to 100 plus job sites,
including social media networks like Facebook and Twitter,
all with a single click.
Find candidates in any city or industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch your qualified candidates roll into ZipRecruiter's.
Easy to use interface,
no juggling emails or calls to your office.
Quickly screen candidates,
rate them and hire the person fast.
Find out today why zip?
Yeah.
[inaudible] has been used by over 1 million businesses and right now my
listeners can post jobs does.
Yep.
For free by going to
ziprecruiter.com/burr.
That's ziprecruiter.com/ [inaudible] one more time.
ziprecruiter.com/barb.
Alright,
I guess we got a few more to go here,
but let's,
uh,
I'll break them up here again.
Again,
there's no fucking way you want to listen to me to do six of these in a,
in a,
in a row.
MMM.
Breaking News,
Trump and Obama meeting at the White House.
Well,
it's fucking lady who's moving or fucking arms around talking,
talking,
talking.
Shut the fuck.
I mean,
I got a lot of nerve telling people to shut up.
MMM.
This is,
you know something.
This is going to be,
this is why is the right so fucking crazy.
What is wrong with you guys?
Jesus Christ.
You pick the reality show TV star.
That's who the fuck you picked.
Then you picked George W.
Bush.
Hey Sharon critique here.
Can you give me a guy?
You know,
this is what kills me about you.
Dumb fucks over there.
I I lean right a lot.
I lean left too.
Sometimes I'm liberal.
Sometimes I'm,
but for fuck's
sakes,
can you get me a guy that could give a speech?
You haven't done it since.
Herbert Walker Bush.
He gave a great speech.
I like that guy.
I had no fucking beat with that guy.
Now I'm going to go from my shack or chicken.
I could check for fucking eight years.
Right?
I didn't like everything that Obama did,
but she got it.
You have to admit,
even you fucking racist cops.
Got To admit that guy was phenomenal speaker.
Phenomenal speaker is fucking hilarious.
He wasn't an embarrassment to hear the world talking.
Now we're going to have a fucking Trump,
Jesus Christ.
Oh,
it's unbelievable.
I've got a lot of nerve cause I actually liked Bernie Sanders watching that guy
give his speech.
Jesus Christ.
It was like he was at a town meeting
[inaudible] fucking hands flapping all over the place.
You know what?
I don't know if there was,
there wasn't a right choice in this one.
There really wasn't.
All right.
Now the,
the marines,
well gonna most of the two best guys in the world.
Yeah.
How do they think they've got to have now the,
how the fuck did they do that?
Where they face each other?
They pause for a second.
Right.
And then they put the same time.
They both fucking,
ah,
they salute.
You know what I mean?
It's like you have to listen to led Zeppelin and then they,
they all just fucking the play in the play and then the song just stops and then
they come back in again.
And sometimes it's on time.
Sometimes it isn't.
It's cause you know somebody just,
yeah,
it's a look that give somebody look and then boom,
you look at these fucking marines said they don't give each other.
We look.
They still brought their fucking hand up at the same time.
There's gotta be some sort of,
some sort of marine,
a little wiggle with an eyebrow.
Granted we are like 40 yards away with the camera and then I'm sitting in a
fucking hotel room.
I wonder what the fucking audition was to get that Gig.
Yeah.
You know,
how many fucking doors did you have to open?
Like perfectly to be there.
You know,
it's gotta be some proud mom out there.
That's my son.
He's going to open the door.
What was the last time a president with the toupee
was president.
They've all had full heads of hair.
All have full heads of hair.
Hey ladies,
who's going to be the next lady president?
I mean the next,
the first one I should say.
Do you think Hillary's done?
Do you think she has enough pants?
Suits for another run?
You know,
I dunno.
I just hope she goes to a chiropractor and gets her fucking neck fixed because I
don't what she was like a baby,
you know?
I,
you fucking,
you know,
babies can hold their heads up.
She kind of was fucking flopping all around.
Um,
I love the pantsuit though.
You know what I mean?
If I was a fucking check of a certain age,
you know what I mean?
I had the kids already,
you know,
shut down
the park,
if you know what I mean.
You know,
hot flashes are over,
right?
Wally world's closed for renovations,
you know,
then you got to rock the fucking pants suit.
You got to get the shorter fucking hair.
Like,
I don't give a shit anymore.
You know,
my husband's old.
What's he gonna do?
Ah,
he ain't going anywhere.
And you go out,
right?
You get the Ellen degeneres haircut and you go out and you get a fucking pants
suit walk around and some flatties for once in your life.
You fucking concerned about your own comfort,
you know?
Ah,
man.
You know what?
If I was Hillary,
my next fucking move is you're more,
Johnny Carson had his own line of fucking sport coats.
I would have my own line of fucking pants suits.
Right.
But you get people like Rihanna,
people in the prime of their fucking life that like walking around half naked
and they somehow,
you know the sound out turn the pants suit.
Who the fuck is is good looking enough in their twenties to make the fucking
pants suit come back.
You know,
I,
you know,
I don't mind the pantsuit when I was coming up the fucking,
Rhoda had them,
Mary Tyler Moore had them,
you know what I mean?
And they will fucking young,
broad say I was sitting there as a little fucking fire,
bald fucking freckled jerk off.
And I would,
I would watch all of those fucking Charlie's angels that they will use to wear
them for Pfizer killed the fuck at pantsuit.
But the parents do back then was sorta like the diversion of the John Travolta
Su.
You know what I mean?
It was just a bunch of ray on and no condoms in the 70s and that's,
that's how we ended up where we're at.
That's why the fucking Rhodes is so god damn filled up.
MMM.
Oh Jesus.
The sound down on em,
MSNBC right now.
Just looking at the looks on people's faces.
I don't know why this shit is so funny to me because I am not thrilled with this
guy being president.
But seeing people disappointed and crying on television,
you know,
past,
obviously if somebody they love died or something like that,
that I don't laugh at that shit.
But like I told you guys are back in the day when the biggest loser was on and
those fat people would just start crying about how they could stop eating
hamburgers and shit.
It just fucking always,
I mean,
I wanted them to lose weight and shit,
but there's just something,
there's something fucking hilarious about people cry,
adults crying.
I don't know why.
It's probably me being a walled off,
you know,
I'm not actually,
I'm not that fucking walled up,
walled off.
Right.
I can get choked up with the best of them.
But if I did it,
you know,
I expect people to laugh at me.
Um,
this is when you know you have too much news coverage.
I'm sitting here watching this marine opening and closing a door and these
fucking nerd guys keep
from the press.
Keep walking in and out of the shot.
Look at this.
There's a lady right now,
she's backing up to take a picture with their cell phone of,
I dunno what now the marines opening the door.
She walks out.
You really,
you know what?
There's actually great that she was in there just to see.
MMM.
Who the fuck just walked out of the place?
What was that like?
His cousins or something.
Okay.
That's such a weird gig.
Does that mean you're a good marine
but they make you like the fucking bellhop or the White House?
I know at the end of the day,
I mean,
you went through all of that fucking training.
You can snap somebody's neck,
right?
Can fucking shoot somebody from 200 yards away and then yeah.
What's,
what should detail.
You're going to open and close the back door at the White House.
And then what?
Nah,
that's it.
You can be dressed in your formal,
so you're going to have your whites on and you're just going to stand at fucking
attention.
There's no way that anybody can do that.
It's gotta be like two hours shifts.
How long can you just stand there?
That fucking straight.
Yeah,
but he's also gotta be of some lunatic comes fucking running up this,
remember that guy jumped over the fucking fence and just ran up and he actually
got into the fucking White House.
That was unbelievable.
That's when I really realized like how not important the president was.
You know,
once again,
they don't even lock the door.
Okay.
Do you understand that fucking ass who jumped over that gate and ran up to the
White House?
Do you realize that that guy got further into the White House than he would've
got into my house?
My door is locked.
Okay.
Then he ran down the hall.
He gave a head fake and he broke the ankles is some secret service guy.
Right?
Like Iverson did the Jordan,
when he first came into the league and he went,
he went to,
he got like
[inaudible] instead of zagged.
And that was the only reason why he didn't just fucking get in there.
It's really not funny,
but you know,
the fact that nothing happened,
that's kind of fucking hilarious.
Um,
Jaisal go scan with this pea soup,
green fucking tie,
just pointing and all that type of stuff.
He's fucking,
yeah.
Geez.
Everybody thinks they're making a point,
including me.
Why don't I read the last few of these things here?
Um,
all right.
Wink,
pronounced wink,
stubby,
Y and Z.
All right.
Finding a great new wine is tough.
That's why I've been telling you all about our sponsors at club,
Debbie,
I wouldn't even voted for Trump.
And how they make it so easy to get wine personalized to your palate and
delivered right to your door.
And here's a little update we have for your club,
Debbie.
Oh Jesus.
What are we going to do now?
This country's fucked is now called wink.
That spelled w.
I,
n.
C,
a new name and an improved look.
But here's the important part.
It's still the same amazing wine company introducing you to new wines you'll
love.
Wink works directly with wine makers and growers from all over the world to
create delicious wine delivered,
uh,
and deliver it right to your door.
Winks 100% satisfaction guarantee means if you don't like a bottle,
uh,
they send you,
they'll replace it with the bottle.
You'll love no questions.
Ash,
um,
you don't just start,
wait,
you don't just get rid,
sent random bottles.
Winks.
WINC is a personalized wine membership that recommends wine specifically for you
based on the results of your palate and profile quiz.
You can also rate all of the wine you receive from Winc.
So they learn about you with every water and constantly personalize the wine
they send.
Sign up for Winc right now and gain immediate insider access to the best fine
wine from all over the world.
Find out for yourself why yours truly and thousands of other satisfied wine
lovers.
I don't love wine.
I drank whiskey.
Why do they always make me do that?
I like Bose.
If you're into wine,
drank the fucking wine gives me a brutal fucking hangover.
Why do you think they switched it from club Debbie?
I always liked it cause I'm Debbie.
He wants to cups.
They all love me,
but they only love me when they,
when I can't understand a,
that's the best part.
Winc is offering my listeners 20% off right now.
When you try,
when you go to try winc.com t r y w I n
c.com/bar.
All right,
they'll,
they'll even cover the shipping.
Hey Lady,
you know you'll love the wine.
Think about it.
You'll get fine wine personalized to your palate,
delivered right to your door.
Try Winc and get $20 off and a complimentary shipping right now.
When you go to try winc.com/ [inaudible] that's try W I N c.com.
All right.
Helux he looks you are unique.
You know,
walk like anyone else,
you know,
talk like anyone else or asleep like everyone else.
So why is your mattress one size fits off well?
Cause the average height is about five,
nine.
You know,
probably that's the reason.
Most part,
we all have arms and legs of fucking head on top of the torso.
So there's,
you know,
why are all bicycles look in the same?
All right.
Cause that's what you fucking feet go.
Then your hands go up there.
And this,
you know,
because the truly co I,
I guess I was wrong because it truly customized mattress will cost you five to
10,000 bucks until now.
Go to helix,
sleep.com answer a few simple questions and they'll run a three d biomechanical
model of your body through the
propriety proprietary algorithms.
I Dunno.
They developed with the help of the way that make your fucking mattress that
fits your body.
The result is the most comfortable mattress you've ever slept on.
A isn't that right sir,
sir?
Oh,
he's already asleep.
That's right.
I have a random person sleeping in here.
A Helix Helix customers report a 30% improvement in overall sleep quality and
for couples,
they customize each side of the mattress.
Your masters or your mattress arrives at your door in about a week and shipping
is 100% free.
That's why everyone from Gq magazine to Forbes are all talking about helix
sleep.
You go once,
you have a hundred nights to try it out.
If you don't like it,
they'll pick it up for free,
gross and give you 100% refund.
No questions asked.
Go to Helen's
sleep.com/bird and get $50 off your order.
That's helix sleep.com/bar one more time.
Hey,
heloc sleep.com/bar is this the last one or the last one?
I'm going to end with a little song here.
People to brighten your spirits.
I had oh boat boat.
These me on d u
who elected Donald Trump.
Boto dude.
[inaudible]
everybody take a dump.
The NYSID saw off like is to pay.
Your balls are dry and you say,
hey,
what the fuck did we just do?
It was either the the clan or the clam [inaudible] that was your selections.
This year,
the clan of the clamp,
I'm me undies.
Picture a world what?
Putting a new pair of underwear isn't just fresh.
You're stepping into a better day.
Think about it.
Underwear is the first thing you put on in the last thing you take off unless
you were fucking Weirdo.
Uh,
why would you settle for anything less than the best feeling underwear on the
planet?
Me On these focuses solely on producing the most comfortable underwear you've
ever experienced.
Well,
that's what you do.
You make underwear.
What would you be doing now?
What else would you be doing?
Huh?
Make it Diorama's my friends at me undies.
These people I've never hung out with who are somehow my friends send me a few
pairs a while back and now I can't imagine wearing anything else that is alike.
I where I'm not even wearing them right now.
Okay.
But what they send me,
we're comfortable except for the Greg losing glue gain is cut.
All right.
Was riding up on my bulls.
Um,
it wasn't even that.
I just,
I could not wear them in front of my wife.
She was just dying laughing at me as I was walking by.
You know what he should've done,
you know,
that fucking crazy things that Olympic swimmers do.
You know where they bend over and then they just start fucking moving their arms
like propellers.
I'm going to do that next time.
Put It on my fucking,
uh,
my Greg Louganis one's right.
I'm going to put on my swimming goggles when my wife is looking.
I'll put it on one of her fucking head wraps and I'm just going to come out and
do that.
All right,
sorry.
Um,
anyways,
for price for the price of two cocktails,
Mandy's,
we'll deliver your new favorite pair of underwear right to your doorstep.
Better Day guaranteed.
Try them on.
And if they're not the most comfortable,
best feeling on these you've ever had,
the refund you and let you keep your last pair of for your first pair for free,
including the,
the prices to sweet touch show,
the sweet caressing touch of modal,
modal,
a special fabric made with the best in class raw materials that are
scientifically proven to be three times softer than cotton.
These Uber Cozy undies are also sold exclusively on me on these websites.
A website where you'll enjoy free shipping in the U S and Canada.
All right?
Here's the call to action is the end right here.
And for a limited time,
everyone in my audience gets 20% off their first order,
but you have to go to our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash bar with me undies.
Better Day guarantee you have nothing to lose,
so don't wait any longer.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash per right now for 20% off your first order.
That's me,
undies.com/bar.
All right?
And that is the,
uh,
that is the Thursday afternoon podcast and a,
and that is the election.
All right?
It is over.
This is the guy that we picked.
And just because you know,
your person didn't win,
it doesn't mean you got to yell at other people.
All right?
You know,
it'd be great is everybody,
if everybody just sort of stop yelling at each other,
okay.
You know,
maybe help each other out.
somebody actually said to me,
you know,
um,
obamacare's going to go away.
How to fuck am I going to pay for my meds?
And that immediately made me think,
wow,
you know what?
Why don't regular people just pick up the slack?
You know,
I don't know how to fuck to do.
It's what sets something up or maybe just help out one person.
What if you're in the prime of your life or your earning power or whatever,
you know,
and somebody down the street needs meds.
You know what?
If you booze a couple of less times a fucking month and you hook them up with
some money to get their meds,
you save you one
and then you won't be [inaudible] is bloated.
You won't be drinking as much booze.
Why don't just regular people help each other out instead of waiting for these
fucking people to do it because they don't get along with each other.
Like when Obama went into office,
evidently all the Republicans on the first fucking day in the house,
the Senate or whatever,
just basically said,
we're just going to disagree with,
we're not going to pass anything that this guy says.
Um,
which is really fucking treasonous behavior,
I think.
Not Saying you've got to pass everything the guy says you do.
Have to keep them in check,
but to before it even comes down the pipe,
you saying,
we're not going to fucking work with this guy.
I don't know.
Um,
so,
but you can't ever expect these assholes to ever get along.
They act like a bunch of fucking babies.
They really are a bunch of babies the way that they behave.
So,
uh,
but that doesn't mean you have to fucking behave like that.
You know,
you could be a,
it can be that person who doesn't scream and yell.
You can be that person that doesn't talk down to somebody because they don't
live near an ocean.
Or You could not judge somebody because they do live near the ocean for whatever
fucking reason.
The blue states near the ocean,
the other ones are fucking in the middle and everybody's screaming and yelling
at each other.
I've gone to all 50 states and Goddammit,
I've met great people out there.
I really have great food,
great fun.
You know,
quit fucking yelling at everybody and now you gotta be all right.
Trump's gonna be president for a lot of people.
I guess it'll be a good thing for other people.
It's not going to be a good thing,
but you know what,
you're not going to die.
Okay.
Get out in front of it.
Think something positive.
The end of the day,
if you want to get your business going,
you're still going to have to do it.
Even if Obama was still in office,
I,
Hillary got,
they're a fucking newt Gingrich or Rudy Giuliani.
The end of the day,
your life is on you and life is not fair.
And people don't have the time to give a shit,
you know?
And that's how it is.
It's unfortunate,
but that is how it is.
But the second you fucking address that,
it's kind of empowering.
Right?
Oh fuck.
I gotta handle this shit.
You know?
And this is coming from a privileged white male,
so
yeah.
Oh,
go fuck yourselves.
All right.
That's the,
that's it.
Okay.
I'm just trying to say shit positive.
Yes.
Oh,
but it's all right.
Well then quit.
Quit moved to fucking Canada was sheriff.
See if anybody gives a fuck.
Um,
anyways.
Uh,
yeah,
it comes to music,
I guess is what happens now.
And then we'll get to listen to some greatest hits before,
uh,
the,
orange toupee guy was,
he made possible even running for president.
Who knows?
Hey,
who do you think he,
you know,
he should pick another reality TV show star for his fucking vice presidency.
You know,
he should get the guy from survivor,
you know,
who gets progressively angrier with every fucking season.
I don't know if you guys have noticed that.
I don't understand.
Like I stopped watching the ears ago because of it.
He just like,
you know,
red team
falling behind.
They got to step it up.
Just starts fucking yelling at him.
He used to just be,
they used to be more excited,
happy.
I think he's just sick of being out on that island,
watching people eating bugs.
I don't know what his issue was,
but he seems to be taking it out on the people there in the islands,
you know,
and say waste away.
Alright,
I'm done.
Babbling.
All right.
Uh,
you have a great weekend.
You're constantly does see on Monday
[inaudible]
hey,
what's going on?
Is the Monday morning podcast to what happened yesterday,
man,
I'll tell you.
Uh,
I was in,
uh,
what the hell was I?
Fort Collins,
Colorado.
I was still forming a Colorado state university and I was going to do the
podcast from there,
but every time I went to call up I couldn't get service.
So that's what happened.
And right now I am in Indianapolis Cause I'm doing Bob and Tom Radio tomorrow
morning to hide my Gig in Nashville.
All right,
so I'm on the road this week.
In fact,
earlier this week I heard that I heard a commercial,
you know that Johnny Cash song where he's like,
I've been to Tupelo stuff stuff,
Brett,
we're rattling off all these cities have been everywhere,
man.
And I literally yelled,
I said,
shut the fuck up Johnny.
Sylvie,
Sylvie.
All right.
So have a lot of fucking people and not to mention the fucking cities he
mentioned in that song aren't just a bunch of cities you wouldn't want to go to
anyways.
Yeah.
I haven't been to any everywhere you fucking Redneck,
you should've said I've been to Paris,
London.
You know what I'm saying?
Rome places people want to go,
not Tupelo,
Toledo,
Charlestown.
Nobody gives a fuck.
And what did you do that Johnny?
Maybe that's why you were so fucking angry.
And that's why I'm so fucking angry because I'd been in those goddamn cities too
when it's,
you know what I like about him?
Let's,
let's turn it around here and make it a little more positive as I go on the 70
east trying to figure out where the fuck up.
There we go.
Um,
you know what I like about them is they're a,
they don't have enough money to Redo that downtown areas.
So you get to see what you know,
you know,
America used to look like,
like 50 years ago,
and I'm not trying to be condescending here.
I actually liked architecture was better,
you know,
stuff was made out of brick.
Everything wasn't like a fucking cheesecake factory and an Applebee's.
Every time that's happened to me in my life.
I've been on the road,
Hey,
I'm good on the front desk.
Do you have any place where I can get something healthy to eat?
Um,
we have an apple base
that's a solution.
He wants something Klc.
Um,
what's healthy?
Oh,
you know what healthy is healthy is when they wrap the silverware in the Napkin.
That means you're eating healthy and you know where they do that.
They do it at Applebee's.
They do what?
It's Shoney's.
Shoney's.
I've never,
um,
never eaten there and show me this certain recipe fucking restaurant.
You just go by those chains and for me anyway,
let me not speak for you.
I don't want to be arrogant here,
but for me anyways,
some certain restaurants,
fast food chains,
I literally just look at the sign and it gives me a stomachache and I can never
eat there.
And Shoney's is one of them.
Steak and shake is another one of the two of them.
I don't know,
maybe I'm combining them.
They have like this orange fucking sign that just,
it just reminds me of what I'm going to feel like after I eat that shit food.
But I'm not always right cause I gotta tell Ya,
I avoided the waffle house like the plague for like a decade on the road.
I would just see that yellow sign with those,
just that regular typescript waffle house and it just,
you know,
you could just drive and buy it.
You knew how sticky the fucking tables we're going to be,
how toothless the waitress was going to be,
how many felonies,
how many convicted felons we're going to be.
It's just,
it just wasn't worth it to get fucking waffle.
Not to mention I have a great recipe for Waffles,
but then you know what I did the rich bitch tour and the two guys I was on tour
with on the Chappelle show one night to let's go to the waffle house.
And I went in there and uh,
you know,
wasn't that bad,
although I gotta admit that it's been so long since I'd been there.
Whatever.
They have their home fries smothered,
covered and all that stuff.
With,
it's fucking gross.
You know,
I don't like you.
I don't mind you.
You're punching up the food a little bit or kicking it up a notch.
Is that uh,
it's gonna say Harold Carmichael.
What the fuck did his name popped?
What's that guy's name?
Emilio.
Emilio Estevez.
What's the name of that chef where he goes,
Bam.
He throws the sugar and everybody goes fucking crazy.
Emilio.
Elios
I think the cell phone is affecting my fucking memory.
What is his name?
Jesus Christ.
Uh,
Emerald.
Yeah,
we'd go Emma.
Look gassy.
Fuck the worst.
You know,
I was trying to remember the name screech yesterday from saved by the bell
because I was talking about,
uh,
people being able to sell tickets.
I couldn't fucking remember his name.
I was like scratchy,
skippy,
Sebastian.
I knew it began with an s,
some sort of harder continent afterwards.
Screech.
Okay.
What would you do if you,
the parent of a child star,
you know,
besides steal his money before he turned 18.
Well,
put the fuck would you do,
especially if,
I mean,
I'll,
I'll give screeches parents a break.
Okay.
But I gotta say from here on out,
if you put your kid into show business,
first of all,
you're fucked in the head.
All right?
You wanted to make it on some level.
And secondly,
if the kid books to show and his character,
his character's name is like 50 or you know,
just something you would name a fucking ferret if the,
if that's what his character's name is.
Yes.
Or uncle,
you just know he's going to be a fuck up.
I,
why did I say Urkel?
Cause he's not a fuck up.
But you know what I'm saying?
That point,
you got to stick to that kid and drug counseling.
You know when,
when he's still eight years old.
Oh my God.
You know what tells me a great fucking show.
Okay,
you could have a scared straight for a child stars.
What you do is you have whoever the next fucking Hannah Montana is,
right?
That's another one.
You fucking name rhymes.
You finished,
she can be on coke on her knees in the bathroom of the viper room within three
years.
I'll wait a minute.
But her dad's Billy Ray Cyrus.
So he knows he's been there.
He's been there baby.
Okay.
You understand whether my eyes look and see the pain that is pain of,
of having a mullet and singing a song called Achy breaky heart.
I swear to God.
No,
it was not for five year olds.
it wasn't.
It was for adults who was for adults and they fucking loved it and they bought
it.
And then one day they figured out it's stuffed and then they all acted locked
than ever bought it and no one will ever come to my shows again.
So I cut off a moat and I'm pregnant at your Mama and then we had you,
well now it's your fucking turn to continue the legacy of horrific fucking
moments in show business.
Um,
oh.
So this is a show.
You basically have
former child stars who've done drugs.
That dude from the courtship of Eddie's father.
Uh,
yeah.
Do you have to do Michael Diamond?
No.
Michael diamond
in the Beastie boys.
Dustin diamond.
Yeah.
Have him fucking in there.
You know your random Brady bunch.
But they never really did anything fucking fags.
They never really did anything just other than linger around
God,
what a boring cast the people,
um,
whatever.
You just take a bunch of child stars who fucked up,
who haven't died yet,
and then you bring them in there and you haven't just started screaming at
whoever the next Urkel is to make sure he's not on drugs.
And if I could somehow smooths it out,
I think I could,
uh,
I could sell that show to VH one,
right.
Stick a former rapper in there,
get some hoes and you've got to show.
So you might be asking yourself built,
you know,
you've been doing this podcast for quite a while.
You've been driving for quite a while on shift your hotel yet.
Uh,
no,
I am not because I'm,
I dunno,
I didn't want to spend the night in Indianapolis even though I have to do radio
tomorrow at six in the morning.
And I looked,
uh,
I saw that the Redwings are playing the fucking,
Pittsburgh penguins up in Detroit,
the best two teams in the NHL last year.
I take a fuck it,
I'll drive up the street.
They can't be more than an hour and a half to Detroit belts.
Turns out it's three hours and I already had a fucking car,
so joke's on me.
This better be a good fucking game.
Um,
but anyways,
I'm driving along here so I don't have the questions.
I don't have to question.
So all I can do,
it's just run my fucking mouth this week.
What should I have done for nine minutes and 51 seconds.
What?
That also includes the intro intro.
I talk to that fucking machine every week.
Um,
all right,
so this is that.
Hey,
there's a waffle house.
Now I'm driving down the road and I'm trying to make the decision,
the decision that Americans have to make everyday in this country.
How do I not become a fat?
Fuck,
I'm Italian.
It's very difficult.
Now here it's very difficult.
Where can I eat at here?
There's a place called Joe's as a throwback.
What is this place?
Joe's Joe's crab shack.
Oh yeah.
That's what I do when I go to the middle of the country.
Let me order some seafood show that's fresh.
The fuck is wrong with you.
I'll tell you,
you know we do in Indianapolis and he likes Sushi.
We love it.
What do you have?
What kind of Sushi?
Trout Sushi.
So sort of fresh.
They have catfish fish Sushi out here.
Oh,
you guys just go down there.
We just,
can we just pull it out of the Crick?
Why does every more on in my act have a southern accent?
I really have to stop that.
I'll tell you why.
Because every time you get outside of a major city,
everybody fucking talks like that.
Everybody's got a little bit of a lazy,
Lazy Way of speaking
that was awful.
Apartments every fucking one looking the same,
but it's right near a manmade lake.
I got to tell you one of the most depressing things ever for me.
Oh,
that's nice.
We just merge down to two lanes.
Were there signs?
Maybe if I wasn't doing the podcast,
can you imagine if I actually caused one of those horrific highway accidents?
You know,
like anybody used to watch that show chips.
Remember that?
Uh,
Erik Estrada,
Larry Wilcox,
bad bad jet jet jet is.
It is
is that in driving down the street and the motorcycles and once you show they
would literally have a 20 to 30 car pile up,
which in all my years of being on the road,
I have never fucking seen it.
My favorite thing about those pileups right
was they would last for like a good fucking,
I don't know,
one minute on television,
which basically in real life is like a five minute catastrophe and everything.
When everything was all said and done,
there's like 25 cars upside down,
twist it around.
It was always like an oil tanker and then there was always that guy.
The last guy would always,
somehow he'd get air off of cars rather than just plowing into them.
He just defined,
he would defy physics and he would somehow get air shoot up and over everybody
and if you listen to the audio,
for some reason the guy would still be hitting the gas.
He's literacy in the air and his car is still going [inaudible]
like he thinks he's going to make it over.
I never understood that even as a little boy,
little lad watching it.
And I look at my dad and I would say,
dad,
why did he do that?
And He'd be like,
shut the fuck up.
Just shut the fuck up.
And the cat's in the cradle and a seal of approval.
Silver Spoon.
There it is.
I'm telling you,
I think the fucking cell phone is affecting my memory.
So anyway,
let's talk conspiracy theories.
Hey everybody.
How about that?
$700 million bail out.
Isn't that awesome?
As an amazing country.
A lot better.
He's fucking motherfuckers.
You know,
I realized after eight years,
you know the [inaudible] is,
it's the goddamn factors.
You know what I mean?
No more fucking terrorists than anybody.
He sons of bitches,
you know what they're doing with that money.
If they lowered interest rates so people can get alone,
fuck no.
GM is going under.
You know what they're doing with the money from what I,
I overheard on the radio,
is there a,
they're using it to buy up other failing banks,
just itching a sports.
The one World Bank,
that's what they're using it for.
And they have the audacity to raise the interest rates on credit cards to help
pay for this mortgage mess.
Then we just give you $700 billion to get you out of it.
I didn't know you were going to keep it so you could buy more assets and then
further,
fuck me in the ass.
It's up to 27% on some people's cards.
Don't they have some sort of usury laws?
There's anybody who's remotely,
I want to say majored in economics because anybody who understands this,
at what point w w what percentage is usually
they're up to 27% I mean,
back in the day did,
did the mob even do that?
They own everybody.
That's when I realized when I really looked at the whole economy that broken
everything down and I realized all the money I've made in this business,
how much of it I've am I ever held in my hand?
You know,
I take out 100 bucks here,
a hundred bucks there.
I pay everything with the check.
I get paid and checks check numbers on a piece of paper.
And I kind of realized that even if I own shit,
they can still be seized
with the Patriot Act that can be arrested,
not charged and fucking waterboard you don't,
I realize I'm going to grow a mustache just in case Evian water pour it.
You know,
it's like you're still going to slowly draw me,
right.
Take water going up my nose.
It's going to grow in those big fucking 1976 symbols.
Mustaches,
you know Burt Reynolds,
you know,
he's got the best mustache ever.
And of course,
I don't know his name.
He's a guy who was in the,
uh,
he was actually in the big Lebowski.
He was the narrator.
Sam Elliott.
I mean that guy's mustache.
It's just,
it's fucking ridiculous.
Number one,
a mustache wasn't cool for like 20 years,
but he kept his,
his was so fucking cool.
You couldn't question his mustache.
That's like a man that's like a fucking panning for gold in the
1847 when the gold rush was anybody listen to this from San Francisco.
And he went out there and you're saying those awful fucking songs.
Oh my Darwin Oman.
Darlin Darlin Klamath time.
You got the worst fucking name in the world.
You must be an ugly bitch.
Has there ever been a good looking woman named Clementine?
You notice that there's like hot girl names like Natasha.
I've never seen an ugly girl named Natasha yet.
I've never seen a cool girl named Natasha.
I always just see some hot girl who knows she's fucking hot at eight because her
name is Natasha,
which ends up making a B.
Really,
um,
uh,
con be honest with you.
Or is it more about me than I never had the courage to approach a girl named
Natasha Natasha.
That's actually about Brooke.
That's a good one.
Brooke.
Natasha.
Uh,
not Melissa.
Let's just can kind of be down to earth.
Some sort of offshoot of Melissa that I always noticed was what the fuck?
I don't know Jesus Christ as if the pressing out here,
it is absolutely overcast.
I'll tell you,
the Midwest Midwestern,
the summertime,
when all the props,
you know,
a waving in the air,
makes you proud to be an American.
But when you're out here,
the beginning of winter,
you start to understand crystal meth.
I get it now I understand the anger of slipknot.
I never understood those guys.
Like what the fuck are they so angry about?
And then I was in Iowa in like February and I was like,
you know what?
I get it.
It's like a,
I dunno,
it,
it really fucking affects your mood.
This is awful for those guys looking for guys in the side of the road.
Then that's why those guys you see on the side of the road,
you're not picking up litter.
You know,
you're not mowing the grass.
You're not waiting to give somebody a ticket,
but you still got a little shine,
a little fucking siren on top of you car.
It's the neutral one though.
That orange one.
It's
like the,
uh,
that's
like the Jen Brady of emergency vehicles.
Oh,
the dad is super eight motel with an indoor pool.
Huh?
Who says this country's in trouble?
In trouble.
Wow.
They've really,
they really stepped it up.
They finally living up to that name.
Super Eight.
Never Super.
When I went to it,
there's a steak and shake.
Next exit.
Oh,
this is this part of the country.
For those you who don't travel,
this is steak and shake.
Dairy Queen country heartland resort camping.
Do you know I had a,
I had a chance to go skeet shooting and DC and I got so fucking drunk with Joe
to Rosa the night before.
I couldn't do it.
Me and Joe de Rosa,
the guy I do uninformed with,
we are not good for each other.
That's what I realized when I think when we're by ourselves we can make good
decisions,
but when we are hanging out together,
everyone else,
you've got a friend like that.
We're after a while,
you know you just have to kind of tap out.
I'm not saying I'm not going to be friends with Joe to Rosa anymore.
I just,
I dunno.
I don't think I can hang out with them anymore.
Why are you driving so fucking slow in the left lane with your high performance
muffler
type performance?
Mufflers a ridiculous,
didn't somebody sends something in about those being overrated?
Is Food Little Asian girls into thinking that you have a fast car?
Bye.
You think it's an old guy with white hair or is that a baseball cap?
Basically a Honda civic.
Early nineties
see ya.
Okay.
With the hatchback,
it looks like he's got some sort of erector set
suspension and you remember that shit.
Maybe erectus stuff that's back when they used to give you toys to try to make
it smart to give like a chemistry set.
Can you hear that?
Can you hear his car?
Well Wah Wah Wah.
No one's fucking 65
he sounds like a motorcycle off in the distance and he's literally fucking 30
yards in front of me.
Some physics major out there doing the math right now to see if I'm not,
if I'm following too closely behind.
Yeah.
All right,
so we're up to 20 minutes.
That's not bad.
You know I,
this is how I used to do them.
It was like an old school one throw back,
a fucking throw back.
Um,
uh,
I'm really going to be hating this drive when I come back to you realize that
I'm such a mate.
Why doesn't this guy have a side view mirror?
Okay,
here we go.
I'm driving by him and it is,
uh,
you know what?
It was a younger kid and he had one of those,
uh,
you know the goatee where you don't have the mustache,
but then you have like the really long shit hanging off your Chin basically says
,
uh,
you know,
I'm not wearing a condom.
Um,
I dunno.
Anyways,
let's,
let's heighten my gigs upcoming this week.
Okay.
If you've enjoyed this podcast and you have a radio,
I will be,
uh,
on the Bob and Tom Show,
um,
tomorrow morning all across this great country of ours,
which is still great.
If we could get rid of these motherfucking bankers.
Um,
and I'm going to be hyping my upcoming Gig,
the next gig on the uninformed tour and uh,
xannies and Nashville,
Tennessee.
Um,
on this Thursday,
Friday and Saturday,
me and Joe to Rosa two man show.
We're going to be a telling some jokes or whatever.
And uh,
he came and saw me last year.
I wrote a whole new hour people in Nashville and listen to this.
I want to go skeet shooting.
I blew it in DC.
I want to go.
I want to learn how to shoot something.
That's my next pocket move.
Was I planned for the new world order?
Um,
so come on man.
I'm going down in Nashville.
I know what's The music city?
Capitol of the world.
But God dammit,
just outside of it.
I know there's a bunch of people with guns and he got fields and I want to go up
there and shoot little plate disks is,
why don't you hook me up?
I got,
I got it.
Here you go.
Anybody who hooked me up,
take me out.
Go skeet shooting gets a free three,
three,
three DVD.
Say That 10 times fast for you.
Your buddy,
you go hunting within your best girlfriend with them.
Daisy Dukes,
mother fucker.
I'm serious.
I want to,
I want to learn.
Okay.
Hey is his kid's mind greatest fucking conspiracy that I know they're going to
combine this country with fucking Mexico and with Canada.
Aside from the fact that they got that creepy commercial about how they have a
new enhanced driver's license that'll make it easier to travel between the
United States,
Canada and Mexico.
Personally,
I didn't know that was a problem.
I don't,
there was people around here going,
you know,
I love this country,
but I just wish it was easier to go to Canada.
God Damn it.
If I could just go to Mexico a little bit earlier,
I mean easier.
This is my big conspiracy.
I've noticed lately I'm traveling and airports and all of a sudden there's this
new software out there called the Rosetta stone,
which is a
Goddamn,
and I wish I looked it up.
I know that Rosetta stone is some sort of,
I don't,
I didn't know what the fuck it is.
It's something difficult.
Is it like the hope diamond?
I don't know what it is,
but basically they took that name and it is now a software that teaches you a
bunch of different languages.
Okay.
Which I always thought was cool.
I want to learn another language,
but nobody in America has ever given a fuck.
Now all of a sudden they're selling these fucking things.
I was just getting off at the airport.
I can see if you're in New York,
if you're in Las hung delays where you could actually speak Spanish every
fucking three feet.
I get it
from maybe French or something like that.
I don't know,
but like I just got off it I the airport here in Indianapolis and this selling
the resent a stone software.
Who the fuck in Indianapolis
is clamoring to learn a different language?
You know something's going on.
They're putting it in your head and I'm telling you,
if you stick it around,
stick it out in front of people long enough they can.
It's like Rubik's cubes when you really think about it.
Was that thing fun?
It was kind of like a toy that was fixed and you spun it three times and then it
was broken and you can never get it fixed again unless you had an Asian friend
who for some reason figured out how to do it.
I don't know what it is about those guys.
They just fucking smarter than us.
Is that like reverse racist in a way?
Because I actually said something,
uh,
fucking
you allowed to do that and I know you're not allowed to say something bad
straight across the bottom.
A race of people.
Can I say something good?
The politically correct police going to come at me.
Now that's just as bad because that's offensive to stupid Asian people.
It's going to make them feel even more retarded and we don't want that.
Um,
anyways.
Wow.
I am really out here in the heartland right now.
You know something?
People always say like,
that's the movement.
Start a farm,
start a farm,
save your money and that type of shit.
But as far as I can tell,
these farmers are fucked too.
What are you,
because they only grow one crop.
So what are you going to do?
What are you going to grow?
Fucking corn,
you know?
All right,
you grow corn,
then everything goes down.
You can't afford food.
Even if he got well water on you,
on your fucking property.
When you eat corn every fucking day.
Some point you got,
I guess maybe you can go out and shoot a pheasant
knows,
reminds me of a joke.
I used to wait a minute,
the hall of fame,
Nem,
Indiana basketball hall of fame.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Jesus Christ.
That's going to be the big biggest collection of white basketball players with
booty shorts in the goddamn countries.
And you know Larry Bird,
he said Jesus,
and I can't argue with them.
Larry Bird.
Now there is,
it was,
it was an awful mustache.
He at a,
I have a cleft palate mustache at pieces.
That was me.
But you know what actually bought one of those kids a new smile.
So I'm able to do that joke.
Larry Bird had a fucking 14 year old white trash mustache when he was like 28.
I don't think it ever filled in his entire career,
that awful oval face,
goddammit.
He could play,
he could definitely place look at me trash and one of the icons of bus than they
would have thought.
Um,
anyways,
I'm going to end this podcast this week with uh,
with a joke I used to do back in my college days.
I was back in college.
This is what I,
when I do all the,
uh,
my college gigs,
standup gigs back before I was doing mainly clubs.
I used to land at the airport.
So I get around a car,
you know,
grab a couple of cds,
possibly cassette tapes,
depending on what point in my career.
And I drive across,
you know,
the farm lands out here in
the Midwest.
And I ended up getting a joke out of it and this was the joke that was like,
you know,
every time you see farmers on the news,
you always see him bitching about how difficult farming is.
You know what?
I must've driven by 10,000 farms during my standup career.
And you know what?
I've never seen anybody doing shit.
Attract is always parked.
Cows standing around,
there's absolutely no fucking activity whatsoever.
And there's always a big satellite dish.
They're in there watching fucking ESPN.
And then when the media comes by,
they just smear a bunch of dirt on their face and they're like,
oh my God,
there was a typhoon
joke when something like that.
And you know what,
today is no different.
I just drove by 40 farms.
I have not seen one fucking person.
The lights aren't even on there.
And then napping,
I don't know.
I don't know what they do at the time of year.
All the crops,
it cut down.
Who the fuck knows?
But anyways,
here's something out to all the people on my space.
I would really appreciate it if you would,
uh,
go onto my website [inaudible] dot com and sign up for my mailing list because,
I'm sort of inching my way over to that one more so than the mindspace.
I'll still put shit up on my space,
but,
uh,
I plan to start blogging and all that crap once I get done with this uninformed
tour.
A lot of,
uh,
putting some extras on there because,
you know,
I haven't joined Facebook yet and I just really don't feel like going over to
Facebook and have to add the same 30,000 fucking people that I already have.
So if you go to my website,
then,
you know what I mean,
and I won't spam you.
And plus you're also able to control
what sort of,
uh,
emails you get from me.
Like when I said I was going in Nashville,
I just emailed people on my Nashville lists.
Okay.
So you're not going to get fucking updates from me every week is I have some
sort of Zany picture trying to utilize the web.
This is my one once a week thing that I do,
which I think is a good thing.
Okay.
I usually do it on Mondays.
I fuck around.
I give you a fucking free audio show.
All right?
It's a lot more than that.
Some of these other cons out there doing.
Right?
All right.
That's it.
That's the Monday morning podcast on a Tuesday.
I Apologize,
I didn't get any cell phone service.
So,
uh,
God bless all of you.
God bless the United States of America.
Fuck the bankers.
Please go on the Internet and start reading about banking.
Please read about it and just read what the fuck over it is.
And,
uh,
educate yourself with conspiracy theory that is based in Wikipedia
and youtube videos.
It's not all bad,
everybody.
I don't like this.
I'm telling you,
man,
I don't like Internet.
Internet gets a bad rep and like it.
I like how the everything on the Internet's a lie,
but TV's telling you the truth.
Think about the insanity of that man.
That's fucking ridiculous.
Dip bowls full of Shit.
And so my throwing,
fucking listen to me.
I have a good week.
And please,
if you live anywhere in the Nashville,
please come down,
come out and see me.
Um,
and um,
that is it.
That's it.
All right,
everybody have a good week.
I said that 15 test.
Got Them.
But I want you to know,
I really mean it.
I hope you have a great team.
All right.
God bless.
Easy.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible].